[Music]
[Music]
miss olivia is a distinguished manager
physics career so he needs a little
introduction for any physicists who were
around here but since we're having this
talk at the Media Lab we probably have a
more general crowd so I'll give a quick
introduction even if you're not a high
energy physicist you've probably heard
about his famous work concern in the
early 1980s he'd spend the major
innovator behind the world's first
proton T proton Collider there the CERN
porp Collider there he led the UA one
experiment very large at that time
physics collaboration discovered the
quantum field particles immediate the
weak interaction the W's and the Z he
won the Nobel Prize in Physics for this
work share with Simon Vandermeer the
accelerator expert did in 1984 he has
been the Hinkins professor of physics at
Harvard during that time in the early
90s years the director general of CERN
played a prime role in shaping the Large
Hadron Collider than me an accelerator
in the next room this is this decade
turning on the middle of the decade we
hope don't fall asleep and he's active
in many projects since including the
Icarus on the crane a neutrino Neutron a
neutrino detector under the ground saw
so outside of Rome and other things
including the energy amplifier novel and
safe way of producing nuclear energy of
supporting present-day accelerator
technologies and what is gonna hook talk
to us about today an extrapolation of
these concepts to exciting new prospects
for nuclear rocketry professor Rubio
thank you how do you turn this thing off
it must be so specific just a simple
switch amazing it'll be complicated
about you well first of all I don't know
what I'm doing here a lot what you're
doing here with me but I had the very
nice afternoon looking at all many all
different crazy ideas and unthinkable
ideas and so I feel rather prepared to
tell you about my ideas which are not
that different one you are part toast
tossing around here memory something
probably never happened it will never be
realized but it's worth trying you I
learned that 10% of your ideas can to to
reality well it's good
coefficient if we can do the same with
this I think we'll be in good shape so
anyway the problem is how about getting
to Mars and connected with it is the
question whether nuclear power can be
used for that there is a group of people
in in Europe working quite quite hard on
this it's about it's been growing at the
beginning with a few people now it's
about oh I'll say 50 60 people working
on these kind of concepts very general
concepts they have no practical
connection for the moment but they show
the need for some new ideas in fact the
need for the ideas is pretty evident do
you know that the initial description of
going to Mars has been done by from
brown in the famous the early book which
he wrote in German when it was a when he
was a war prisoner and in that he
described the standard mechanism to get
there there are a lot of difficulty in
doing this at the present moment you
know many people to the especially NASA
is trying to to get there it's not very
simple but eventually it would seem to
me that this is one of the things when
kind would like to to do I'm surely I
will not be there to see that but I
think it's still fun to think about it
now if you wish to do this kind of jump
from going to the moon 300,000
kilometers to going on to Mars where the
round-trip is a billion kilometers you
have to somehow introduce some
substantial change you cannot use the
same technology over again and the real
question is can you use or would you
like to use and this project is not up
to MIT standards it's totally out of
focus and there's a lot of operations
okay now I would say after harvest
Anders
anyway so the question is do you have to
use can use nuclear power and I think
you can certainly convince yourself a
nuclear power that the sense is
interesting because he offers you three
million times more specific energy than
the chemical reaction when you burn it
all but energy is not the problem when
it's traveling space what important is
in space propulsion is impulse is
momentum is speed and in fact there is a
famous rocket equation which determines
how much stuff you can get there when
you start with a certain initial mass
and this is the ratio between it's very
simple equation which contains here the
sum of the speeds easier to add to the
for various operations and divides up
the speed of exhaust of your gas and
that is essentially fixed by by the by
chemical fuels which can reach
temperature of their order and provide
the specific impulse of the order of 450
seconds I don't know whether you know
what specific impulse is the specific
impulse is the is the essentially the
the amount of time is measuring seconds
the amount of time over which a fuel
will apply a thrust equal to its weight
so if I have a kilogram of certain
material and I burn it
that gives me a kilogram for so much
time and that time is the impulse
specific so essentially it's if you have
a kilogram of chemical fuel it provides
your kilogram of thrust over 450 seconds
and that is essentially specific impulse
which is proportional to speed of
exhaust now the idea is of course to go
nuclear but the nuclear system are
limited in the temperature now you
cannot even get to the temperature of
the gas and because essentially your
materials your reactor is not standing
the high temperature itself and so you
do with the thing called nervous I mean
the machines developing Russia in the
United States 900 seconds we do that
essentially not
because you have a higher temperature
but simply because he using hydrogen and
hydrogen has a slower atomic number so
molecules move faster and therefore you
get higher speed of exhaust now in in
other words this is a little bit the
situation if you look at the standard
here is the stagnation temperature
temperature which your system is
operating here is liquid hydrogen oxygen
gives you a exhaust speed of about four
hundred four thousand four kilometers
per second so an impulse Pacific can
pass about 450 and we are talking about
machine so if you like systems which
should allow you to get two temperatures
which are typical in the order between
10,000 and 15,000 degrees this is
hydrogen exposed and the specific
impulses which are in the region between
2500 and maybe 400 for 4000 so we're
talking about an order of magnitude
improvement in the in the specific
impulse a respect to the system based
with normal chemical system factor 10 in
speed means the factor 100 specific
energy let's be clear that and that of
course makes the situation much easier
when you try to go to Mars in fact the
most used trajectory is so-called
minimum energy trajectories called a
home a trajectory the one which was used
by was proposed initially by as I said
by the original thing document book I
was telling you before the travel time
is long is 280 days it's essentially
free fall trajectory as you'll see in a
minute however if you get there and then
you want to come back you have to make
sure that the planets are in the right
place and that means that you have to
add another four hundred sixty days
residence so it's a fixed trajectory
which should go for a year and stay
there year and a half and then come back
here and if you miss the opportunity of
course things are not in the right place
and then you don't get anywhere now if
you want to get a little faster with
this you have to do catch up on the
motion of the earth and that in fact
requires much higher transfer fees Lao
explain you what I mean if I now let's
look at this curve here you see here you
have the essentially represented here
the my answer residence time and you
have the four hundred sixty six hundred
forty days there which corresponds seven
six hundred forty days which corresponds
to the number I gave you before five
hundred forty days and then you see here
the various this is the Holman
trajectory and then you see all these
lines are possible they are
characterized of course by by fast
transient velocity but they give you the
same residence time which is of the
order of a couple of years if you want
to go to a much shorter time mission you
have to go in UI you have to make
conjunction tragic in other words here
to run after the earth which is scaping
away from you and that implies that you
have to go to much faster speeds this is
the area which is permitted there is no
other way in between so if you have very
slow move motions 5 kilometers per
second then you will be forced to do
that if you want to get to stay there
for me less time you are obliged to to
go to speeds transfer speeds which are
in fact quite large 25 30 kilometers per
second which implies of course is speeds
of your of your ejected gas of the same
order magnitude and therefore you
require new methods we are talking about
now missions of this type for the man
clipper missions and missions that slice
stay there for the case of of
transporting materials now let me show
you briefly how this mission can be
realized the fast mission as a set
consists of living the earth here and
then running on this trajectory and
getting here after hundred fifty days of
Mars then you stay on Mars as long as
you wish from zero to hundred days or
whatever is required and then you decide
to come back if you want to come back
this time you have to the earth is gone
further so you got you have to catch up
the earth position so you have to run
much closer to the Sun
and then make it turn inwards and that
allows you to get back in something like
his I say another under seventy day in
night days but so therefore you can
close the whole thing in a year but it
requires speeds of as I said much higher
this is for the people which won't get
there now if you want to go and send
equipment as you probably need anyway
then you can follow the hormone
trajectory which is the one represented
here and you can see what the almond
trajectory is all about is a half a
circle you start here you go in 280 days
to Mars 20 60 days then used to have to
stay all this time until such a time as
the as the earth is in the right
position and you live here and then you
go another Ouma trajectory back 180
degrees like bang and you hit the earth
where he belongs
that is affected a long long time trip
now we are trying to study all kinds of
emissions with the potentialities this
new engine which I'll describe in a
minute essentially nuclear power is
going all to be used only for transplant
or a trip classic at Bethel for landing
it takes off so you use standard fuel to
get to to orbit and then to come down
air braking is being removed at this
level a break is the Streamy complicated
procedure you machen you arrive on Mars
and then you have to get into sort of a
orbit which is slowing down into the gas
of Mars and the wind is very narrow the
difficulties of doing that of
considerable in fact many problems are
getting worse material come from that
point we like we think that with people
you should avoid it the space station
alpha is used as a departure and the
transplant meant me mission needs a
reusable shuttle
since many trips are necessary and could
be necessary and this device will in
fact operate on a periodicity of Earth
Mars orbits which is 740 days and the
question is presence on Mars so that man
is necessary for the complexity task but
not about the harsh environment limits a
stay to short time it's a conceivable
you can leave a person for the first
time on Mars one or a few years
eventually
make his own few will and come back and
so forth so he has to be able to go
there to get the equipment going but
then then he has to come back and you
need no sharp departure window and then
you have to kinda missions the Clipper
for fast main transit and the tag for
material transportation which can be low
slow and the key of course of that is a
higher specific impulse now the present
state of nuclear propulsion is not a
very good state essentially Nerva is the
design which is now the best in town and
say essentially gas core fast reactor
the maximum temperature is determined by
the temperature of this uranium
zirconium niobium carbide which has to
remain solid he runs at high pressure
because he has to did gas has to go from
here to there here's the low temperature
he has 3,000 degrees so he has to warm
up going through the rods of the
reactors so high operating pressure the
mass of the fuel must be large is one
ton of highly enriched uranium we just
put into orbit in order to get
criticality but however during the
burning of all these system only five
grands are burnt the rest is it just
goes there yet to deliver it get rid of
it and there are particularly people
many people get know very nervous when
you put a ton of highly enriched bond
grade uranium on orbit neutral leakage
is very large 10 to the 19 neutrons a
second so it makes it very hard for
people to stay around you has to be
shielded and even with a good shield
that is not trivial you can avoid that
kind of radiation from cassadee's fluxes
and the real problem is that essentially
that the fuel is in fact the hottest
part in the system now the basic idea is
can we keep the fuel called and the gas
hot that's what you like to do the
answer to that is a very simple idea
which we are working on which is direct
heating or by the fission fragments now
let me remind you that 88% of nuclear
energy do
fishing is carried by two Fisher
fragments the rest being additional
neutrons and in gamma rays you have
essentially raining 2:35 you swallow a
neutron the Orion 235 starts to vibrate
to move it separates like two drops of
water you get you get two little
droplets the both positively charged
therefore the repel each other no longer
nuclear force this force is a present
because you have severed the connection
with two and the 200 MeV your recoveries
are simply the Coulomb repulsion of
these two parts so two fission fragment
come off and they carry essentially
ninety-eight percent of the total
kinetic energy so why not use in
addition there are a few gammas and
neutrons but they carry on if you may be
so most of the energy is carried by
these sufficient fragments which are
back to back so to speak now the
question is why how can you make use of
that Fisher fragment directly they have
an enormous enthalpy inside they
represent remain to high temperature but
then you never see that mean reactor
because they stop it to the reactor then
you get warming up of you material you
don't get access to that beauty that
nature is providing you there with and
so the question is can you use them
directly to heat up the gas the
penetration Rangers Fisher fragments
streaming short is ten microns in the
fuel and usually the energy is converted
in heat inside the fuel and now the
question can you use directly this
fission fragment not to eat the gas and
that will of course give you an enormous
advantage as you see the minute so we
assume a very thin fissile deposit let's
take a foil put on a foil a layer of
fissionable material and then make it
thin enough so that Fisher family can
come out and then see what happens as a
function of the thickness of the foil
here you have plot which says one micron
one milligram per square centimeter at
10 milligram per square centimeters this
foil are made out of uranium a ratio of
whatever you want and you see here the
energetic fraction of energy coming out
you get forty four percent if you had
zero thickens because eighty eight
percent is fish and fragment and forty
four going one direction forty forgot
the other and then when the thickness
becomes bigger you get a loss for this
if you have one micron thickness you get
thirty four percent instead of
forty-four if you go to three microns
milligram per square centimeter get
twenty four percent now what are we
talking about here we are talking about
one milligram per square centimeter
which is point eight microns in
thickness which is 10 grams of a meter
squared surface and we are talking about
1,100 atomic layers this is certainly
not what you call a nuclear fuel a
nuclear fuel is a very heavy material
hundreds of tons of stuff inside the
system he is rather a radioactive source
if you like it deposited on a thin layer
now how do you get criticality now for
that you need to do some clever things
which has to do with neutronics let me
anticipate to you that we I do succeed
in having criticality with that little
bit of a mission now that be clear about
numbers if they take is americium which
is the largest efficient cross-section
and known around five thousand three
hundred barns and you get the neutrons
through that he has one percent
probability of interacting so obviously
you're like to have a hundred percent
probability of interacting to keep the
reaction going and therefore you need
about the fact one hundred enhancement
so can you enhance the neutron flux with
some kind of storage device so that you
can get the neutrons over and over again
through your militia foil and in house
this way the probability of efficient
the answer is yes well we've done lots
of experimental CERN of that and in fact
this is not just a theory it's just an
experimental results the basic idea is
that you take a highly diffusing but
neutrons transparent medium and you let
in that thing a neutron travel only
lasts across sections there there is no
in elasticity so this Neutron moves
around inside this material in the same
way that the
for instance an electron moves in an
argon gas well the physical reason is
very similar normally you're talking
about nuclear which a double magic we
have here great experts for these things
and doubled our magic nucleus is like a
it's like a noble gas and the shell is
closed so in the same way that an
electron cannot capture in argon of
helium and it would go around as a free
electron forever here we are talking
about a nucleus and the neutron will not
capture the nucleus because the shell is
closed and the cross-section is very
small and the result is this thing will
just go around look here this is think a
tortuous path inside the highly fusion
medium this computer-simulated but this
reality is not really different the
neutron is since restored stored not by
like a storage tiering is stirred by
diffusion it's a random process but
effectively it gives them the trans
together and that is in fact as we
showed that effect 60 meters long path
is wound in 35 centimeters one foot in
length and this is due to the fact that
this movement a Rondo now in such a
storage medium so you have a volume of
this type of high purity graphite or
high purity LED in that volume you have
this phenomenon such a storage medium
because of multiple trials even a very
tiny amount of impurity can absorb
absorb a significant amount of of
capture elements suppose you have a ball
full of water and you put there a little
bit of ink just to the drop of ink the
whole box will have a color of the ink
even if the amount of ink is
infinitesimal because the water is
transparent ink is highly absorptive and
sooner or later light will find the
molecule of ink and will send back the
color which you put in and the same
thing happens here you you have a very
small amount of impurities inside this
medium because you go around and around
around over and over again you'll
eventually hit an impurity and then
you'll get a factor because of this
multiple
trial effect and therefore 20 grams of
americium in such a box will make it
critical so now you can make devices
which are critical with
I'm so material not kilograms remember
in the in the Nerva you needed one taunt
of highly fissile highly fissile
bomb-grade uranium here with 20 grams of
ammunition your critical in this
continuum medium now of course you don't
want to continue medium you want to have
essentially the way to to to do this
fission sow wheat reduce a statement
which we call whole round because it
reminds of a black body which is
essentially a box which by the high
purity caramel diffuser which walls you
put a thin layer 1 micron thousand
molecular layers of americium and then
what happens neutrons will ping-pong
between the walls of this container
would traverse many times the walls and
it will and enhance today interaction
probability as we will see in a minute
about 100 falls and the ultra-thin
fissile layer requires a final Fischer
probability because of this many
traversals and the newly Fischer produce
produce neutrons of course will get
thrown into the box and will start again
more precisely we assume the empty
cavity is covered with a layer the
configuration is similar to a blackbody
radiator and I'll let you remind you the
blackbody radiation flux is uniform in
depend on the shape and the flux is
determined essentially by the properties
the material not by the geometry the
same thing will also happen here and
easily for independent shape of the
cavity provided of course it will
behaved and therefore it doesn't matter
what the shape is you will get this
result and also make due to temperature
and therefore Neutron energy will be
related sensor dot that by the fuel but
the quality of the of the container so
temperature will be it will be fully
terrorized with a temperature of your
container so you'll know very precisely
what the energy neutrons you're dealing
with and of course no Neutron will come
out because being a blackbody it will
contain a neutrons inside if they're
inside they're not outside
now the theory of enhancement can be
easily done I will not spend much time
with this it tells you that the if you
have a any shape and you take the a
reflector away and then you put it back
and you leave the same source and you
asked to change enhancement to the flux
because of the reflector on that the
enhancement factor is equal to that
expression which is square root of the
last scattering for the capture cross
section of scattering elastic is
typically 10 barns capture cross section
is order of Milli barns so we're talking
about ratio 10 to the 4 10 to the 5
between the two numbers and therefore
when you take a square root you get good
results and the two parameters which are
important here one is the diffusion
length diffusion length which means the
size of your sphere of containment in
other words the thickness of your walls
did you have to use to do the job and
the second one is enhancement factor how
biomass you increase the flux now if you
get graphite you get 27 centimeters
diffusion length and you get 94 94
annoucement beryllium will do fine as
well it is much smaller it's 12
centimeters but the enhancement factor
only 73 lithium will we be completely
transparent and liquid deuterium would
even an enormous advance of factor but
they also very long length so you'll
have to build a huge device is not
practical and lipid hydrogen is also
screwed it so essentially you are ending
up with beryllium and beryllium oxide
and carbon is interesting materials and
then you try to calculate with this
system criticality and you do achieve
criticality rather rapidly
here is the thickness of the carbon wall
which is increased sorry here I increase
the thickness of the carbon wall and
then here I put the K value which means
a cake will one miss criticality means
you get back as many neutrons that you
made and if I have a layer of one
milligram per square centimeter 1100
layers you can see I get critical with
about 250
the gram per square centimeter which
means one meter twenty of a carbon it's
a bit too much but if I go to three
milligrams
you see I'm already running a 75 here
grams per square centimeter which means
about 35 centimeters which is that much
this is 22 centimeters you haven't grown
in flying over the Atlantic that's minus
22 centimeters and so it's quite a
reasonably small amount of reflector and
beryllium oxide can do it fine even
better and you can see that indeed
criticality is obtained with layers
which are only a few milligrams the
square centimeter so it is possible with
this technology to make a critical
reactor which will operate with a very
small amount of material remember one
milligram per square centimeter is 10
grams per square meter surface we are
talking about probably hundred square
meters for this mission so we're talking
about between five and ten kilograms to
off americium to burn which is not very
much in fact americium has the same
property is uranium 232 Tonio 238 which
is used now on on Cassini mission and
was Voyager and usually you had more
than kilograms on it so it's - a V as
one says in French now the problem is
which fuel element you like to lose very
quickly yes the high fishing probability
accepted a long lifetime and not too
extravagant production procedure now of
course I'm a ratio - 42 M is an ideal
device this is the cross section notice
the cross section drops when a
temperature goes up this is the
temperature of your whole round thousand
degrees 2,000 degrees so you're running
here in this region that correspond to
the energies captures very high fish and
very high capture very small big ratio
between the two now if the other element
which is not so bad is Polonia to
plutonium-239
which is well known as a is a resonance
here at about 0.3 put point two four
electron volts so that could be used if
you were to make a container which has
high temperature for instance of the
order of 3,000 degrees then in this case
you could also use
but you'll have problem of temperature
coefficient here is your very nice
negative temperature coefficient because
of this color section so plutonium is a
second choice americium is the first
choice
so I've done a very complete burn up
through a reactor or this type I'm not
spending time to discuss that here is
what happens when you take 1.4 kilograms
of that americium and you burn it you
can have a fairly long burn up burn up
means megawatt they kill up a megawatt x
day per kilogram means one kilogram will
give you that many megawatt that many
days so one kilogram here will give you
400 megawatts for one day or 400 1
megawatt for 400 days which is much
bigger than what you get for a normal
reactor you normally act you get to burn
up a 20-30 in those units essentially
comes from the fact that the system is
much more efficient when it comes to
burning for instance here you can see
during this 500 kilogram day 500
megawatt day a per kilogram the
americium coming down from 1.4 kilograms
to about 0.7 americium being burnt a
million to 43 produced by the captures
since it's a clean situation and here
stops because it gets below critical and
so you can get a lot of energy out of
this you can burn about half even more
than half of your Mauricio I can go and
3 milligram per square centimeter layer
delivers that much power and of course
if you much longer operation you have to
remake you your layer it's a very thin
layer here it can be deposited in some
kind of a way this is the whole
technologies to be developed but
obviously periodically fueling may have
to be visit eventually now how do you
produce the americium very rapidly well
essentially you start from Mary Mary
Shinto 41 which is naturally grown in
aged reactor spend fewer Plutonian to 41
a lifetime of 14 years and goes to
americium and then you make a neutron
capture and here is plan explain how you
do the neutron capture
then you get an extra Neutron and you
end up to 242 m242 not M is not it's not
stable and so the only thing left is
that one
so let's come back to the question of
heating of the gas with those fission
fragments and so let's assume you have a
tube typically we are talking about the
tube which is two and half meters long
30 meter in centimeter Indiana this is
like if you arrived in reactor only if
you were other reactors full of material
and the cooling is outside here we are
talking about a funeral which is empty
and the fuel instead of being a
depositors the volume is deposit of the
surface inside and then we get gas in
and then the gas goes through this thing
and it gets heated up let's see what
happens here you have a tube 30
centimeter in diameter this particular
case 1 meter 2 meter 50 long there is a
thin wall which cooled from liquid from
outside and produces to watch the square
centimeter heat and produces 3.95
megawatts of power these rod is immersed
as you'll see in a little bath on this
wall there is americium 3 milligram per
square millimeter this total gram is 72
thermal 71 grams so it's not very much
and there is a little bit of gas flowing
through this system
1.2 grams per second so 58 microgram per
square centimeter so it's very slow flow
gas the whole damn thing is taking one
gram of gas per second and the gas is
flowing very slowly it leaves the wall
it departs from the wall which Purse
world warms up and when it comes down
here you will see from exact calculation
has temperatures the order of 10,000
15,000 degrees and in fact it's the wall
a cold and the gas is hot so it's
maintained this is my statement
maintained top foil the reasonable
temperature cooling from outside the
wall the sheet the the foil and and the
gas is moving from the wall and when he
gets in it gets hot
and by the time it comes down there he
goes between ten thousand fifteen
thousand degrees C now which limits
there are and how can you get there now
temperature limitation due to the
mechanical strength of nuclear fuel
are removed because the fuel is called
and the gas is homes now there is
another server gifts of nature in here
which are worth reminding you first of
all the range of the fission fragments
exiting from three miracle materials be
calculated for the actual detonate
distribution and it turns out that the
specific ionization per unit of mass is
in hydrogen much greater than 1 in in a
militiaman there is almost the fact that
twenty higher specification ization lost
in hydrogen respect to a militia what is
due to at food what's the cause of that
because to that is the following that
ionization losses only worked when the
particle traveling is faster than the
electron bound in the atom and the
fission fragments beta equal point of
four four percent so many of the
electrons bound in in the americium foil
have a speed which is higher than the
speed of the of the of the of the
fission fragments and therefore they
essentially not participate in to you
news Asian laws if you take hydrogen
well the velocities is his 101 over
alpha and therefore it's much smaller
than the velocity the facia fragment so
that you have a high organization losses
you can see here that the the arrange
all these fission fragments gives about
10 microns in as I said in americium but
less than 0.5 micron in in gas so you
get an enhancement we factor 20 in
immunization losses in the gas which is
affect extremely important and so even
half a milligram per square centimeter
gas will absorb the fission fragment
completely so you can operate with very
low pressure actually in reality the
fission Frank we go in all possible
directions of the range is only the
upper limit to the travel so let me take
two for infinite planes coated with
americium defining volume filled with
the hydrogen gas so you have two planes
here and these two planes are now
filled with gas and the fissure
fragments reversing it the thickness is
half a milligram per square centimeter
so it's about 220 centimeter 3
atmospheres to get ourselves understood
even high temperature and and then you
have this is the kind of heat produced
by the wall to left this is the kind of
heat produced by the wall to the right
and when you put them together you get a
reasonably flat distribution the
important number here is this very
simple one one dimensional this drawing
which in fact will be is worse than the
case of the tube which I'll discuss two
dimension in a minute you get with 400
watts per square centimeters on the on
this foil you get about half a megawatt
per gram in the gas now a mega watt is
enormous power mega watt in a gram is
just putting a mega watt on an on a or
the mosquito and obviously if you put a
mega watt on a mosquito you will give it
quite if it will fry very rapidly and
therefore the idea is that you can keep
the the foil under very normal condition
of reactor but get a real hell inside
the gas as I said you can get mega watt
per gram with VAT hundreds of AD per
square centimeter on the wall now this
whole thing is plane following way here
you have in this curve here the VATS
unfortunately it's hard to see it's I
cannot even see myself I wonder whether
you can read you see over there
here you have one megawatt per gram
hundred kilowatt per gram 10 megawatts
per gram and here for surfers power
density watts per square centimeter 100
watts per square centimeter 400 watts
per square centimeter 800 watt 2 squares
I mean this is the kind of region which
you normal reactors operating and you
can see that you can go all weight up to
about a megawatt per but gram in the gas
with reasonable heating on it on the
walls and that is of course that
transformed into into temperature
through the entropy diagram for hydrogen
where you have here you have entered
be ten to the five ten to the six this
is in jail program and you have
temperature here 10 to the 3 10 to the 4
4 10 to the 4 now you have to pay little
attention to this curve here up to 3000
degrees the enthalpy is rising linearly
this is a perfect gas enthalpy specific
heat is constant it's essentially a
temperature of a single hydrogen
molecules at about 3,000 degrees the
molecule deceits becomes arable then you
get the enthalpy to do the destruction
and that is like a chemical reaction you
put energy in it eventually come back
after you've done it and then you start
with another slope which is twice as
sharp because you have twice as many
atoms there and therefore you have a
higher specific heat contained for a
given gas and then you get to about
10,000 degrees when you get to 10,000
degrees the gas gets ionized and then
you are getting the 13 electron volts
off of ionization remember 10k 10,000
degrees Kelvin is one electron volt but
here we are talking about having
recovering something like of the order
of 10 electron volts and therefore the
entropy grows tremendously even if the
temperatures don't go very high and
essentially you are now talking about
enthalpy Java gram is equal to power
watts per gram times dwell time trying
which you aren't exposure time gas takes
to come out of the container typically
we are talking about of several seconds
in this machine so we are talking about
seconds multiplied megawatt per gram
equal to GK joule per gram
[ __ ] joule per gram is right here so
we're talking about temperature ten
thousand fifteen thousand degrees and as
well Nerva your fast motion starts short
dwell here you have slow motion long
dwell and this is gives you the impulse
which you can get with ten thousand
degrees you're about 25 kilometers a
second exhaust speed in about 3000 in
specific impulse how much time do I have
left
20 minutes okay fine now then to do that
more clearly we are talking about
parameters of this tube 20 centimeter
radius 2 and 1/2 meters in length and
we're talking about thousand degrees for
the wall final temperature in the gas of
10,000 degrees and we are talking very
small amount of gas coming through
you're talking about essentially speed
of the gas of point 75 centimeter per
second beginning 3 4 5 grams per second
through the system and this is the
heating stage then you have an expansion
cone which brings you down to about
25,000 in 2500 in specific impulse or
25,000 feet per second and with this
thermodynamic efficiency about 30%
now there is one technical point which I
quickly like to mention which is a
substantial limitation to this method to
this system which is which are the
radiative losses of the gas which gets
seated when the gas gets very hot it
starts to radiate emits power away
eventually if the power idiot is more
than the efficient power coming in you
are in trouble
essentially it's a lot of work to
calculate all this there are type of
losses line band a continuum now
remember way that we only have atomic
hydrogen therefore the the molecular
levels are not there and essentially you
are talking about theoretical hydrogen
is beta book one two electrons in the
handbook the physics since then we we
know the numbers so all the calculation
can be done very precisely and it turns
out that the radiated power there is
essentially the line emission is quickly
absorbed essentially the line looks
black because of the the absorption is
in fact quite strongly on the line and
therefore you don't have essentially
it's like the Sun when you look at the
Sun you see the Sun the plasma the Sun
you see lines dark you don't see the
light coming out of it so there is no
radiation for the lines there is a very
substantial band emission
which is which is there has been all
calculated I'm not going to get into
details with this essentially turns out
that what happens is that T the light is
growing with temperature of the gas and
this is frequency and this is the power
after a certain finite distance and it's
it's becoming a lamp a big lamp and here
is the surviving radiated power as a
function of the distance of the gas this
is about one centimeter of gas at 3
atmosphere so most of the light emitted
by the band is absorbed immediately in
the region where is emitted and
therefore i contributes only to heat
conductivity but there is a standard
component which is this flat line here
which is in fact having a very constant
as very long attenuation path and this
is the light you can see on the walls
itself this is all taking to account in
the calculation and essentially it tells
you that up to about 10,000 or 12,000
degrees you can operate and above that
you have a problem of radiation which
you have to solve the other question
which is important is the recombination
of the hydrogen the hydrogen is starting
from being well let me show you here the
curves which is probably the best way of
showing it the hydrogen starts as a
molecule this is the this line here as a
function of temperature
this is logger to be scaled but it
quickly becomes an atom and then about
10,000 degrees it starts to it starts
lionize here for is it 3 atmospheres
here 10,000 degrees that's why ionize
and a 15,000 degrees is about 50 percent
ionized so essentially what happens is
that you're dominating with atomic gas
and above a certain value you also
dominated by by plasma which is
substantially ionized the plasma ready
combination electron proton in lower
self combination of the plasma it's a
very fast reaction because it's a gamma
plus plus neutral hydrogen equal to
electron plus proton is a perfectly
large cross-section the
recombination molecule to Adam it's very
slow remember you two atoms cannot make
a molecule because there is no momentum
energy conservation so a single
collision of two atoms will not make a
molecule because they had me to meet the
gamma and the gamma is not there at
those temperatures and therefore the the
thing is metastable you remember
remember the so-called hydrogen torch
plasma torch in which you take atomic
make molecular hydrogen and you make it
atomic hydrogen and then you throw it on
a wall and when it hits the wall it
becomes a molecular again because he
finds a recoil and therefore it gives
you heat and in fact you can melt lots
of stuff in this way now that is
essentially what's happening in our case
here however is a show at the beginning
first of all the gas is essentially
therefore our gas is frozen in other
words we expected this gas to come out
essentially as an atomic gas however
atomic gas means the a is one stead of
being - and therefore you pick up a
square of the two in the in the number
of of the speed now you gas therefore
although you lose part of the energy
because you're dealing with an atomic
system rather be the molecular system
the effect on the on the specific
impulses are shown in the first
transparency which I hope I can find
again here is quite small essentially
because of the fact that the gas is
reducing it's a and so we have
essentially this gas comes out very cold
when you hit them so the problem of the
of the of the funnel is not an important
point now since we are in a computer
science here let me tell you some
computer simulation so feel a little bit
more at home so what you've done we have
developed a lot of programs which do the
following this is doing fluid dynamics
calculation this is making the official
fragment transport heat release this is
worrying about radiative effects of the
gas and this guy here is combining the
energy losses and energy radiation to
close the loop with the with the with
the program
which is the program on on fluid
dynamics so this is a fluid dynamics
program then it goes into a heating from
fish a frying with the neutronics
providing this supply radiation you lose
power these you make power you take a
Power Balance and you put it back and
you make your current calculations and
then we have done several models here
with a typical twenty centimeters two
and two and half metres machine
simulation rather sophisticated we have
hydrogen in florid Kelvin which is in
fact in fact uniformly distributed and
this thing is really and then you get
essentially various intensity of flow
let me show you some results here is we
are increasing the temperature of the
heater this is half of the cylinder you
can see that is that a half coming on
the other side so you start from the
wall here and when you move on you you
heat up the gas slowly until the gas
gets very hot and then eventually down
here the gas is is the hottest ending
comes out from the from the from the
funnel you say the same thing here case
number three which is the one we
consider most appropriate and you do get
about 10,000 degrees out of that and you
do get essentially how the gas is nicely
hot at the end so the fluid dynamics
works extremely well when this is in
this story actually you can see here
global power power the position and
temperatures and you can see in fact
that these kind of calculations are
perfectly adequate so we have a good
fluid dynamic model of this the heating
process off of the of the fission
fragment in the two dimension is quite
remarkable here we had 200 watts per
square centimeter on the tube and here
we are collecting here 900 watts per the
milligrams so we are collecting 900
kilowatt so one mega
perk per gram off of the gas and you see
here is the radius of the container in
the central part is very uniform these
two lines correspond to the top in the
bottom where there is no no coverage one
hand because you're going out into the
into the nozzle the top because you
there is nothing on the top the the
americium is only the positive decides
if you were to increase the pressure
from two atmospheres to 12 atmospheres
then you will observe this the official
fragment will just stop before they get
to the center and only the science is
heated a few more minutes left I can
describe you here some of the design
consideration as saying this is the kind
of tubes we are talking about and then
this many tubes are inserted inside the
box so let's look at let's look at this
this is a realistic engine this will
carry a mission according to what Naz is
calculating over to Mars and back again
in the way was describing you before
it's made essentially by 30 series of
tubes two and half meters long those
tubes are equivalent to the fuel
elements they have on the bottom the
nozzle and therefore they can be clamped
on on a baseline if you like they
immerse decided sea of lithium liquid
lithium with bath which is the coolant
and this works is a boiling lithium
reactor if you like the lithium is all
around here and he touches the outside
of tubes so that the outside wall is
cooled with lithium and the lithium is
traveling all over here there are
control bars coming into the into the
whole realm so you take away the
neutrons to control the the process the
system is essentially a water lithium
cool system you have lithium which boils
lithium becomes vapor the vapour lithium
goes to the panels which are the cooling
panels there it condenses again it
becomes
quit and in his Rico likely to put back
again so he operates the constant
temperature but there is the heating the
fraction the heat which is used by the
evaporating boil off heat which is for
cooling these are the numbers indicated
here this we are talking about thrust
power 30 mega VAT the overall thrust
efficient is 17 percent 177 mega watts
the consumption total exhaust speed 35
km/h / second propellant flow is 50
grams so hydrogen per second the Trust
is about 2000 Newton's the foil power
density is 200 square centimeters there
are 88 square meters of of a mere issue
and this machine will run with 2.4
kilograms of americium so very little
and the refueling time will be every
nine days every nine days you go in
there you just put your tubes or
whatever to get going so we're talking
about few kilograms of material and you
can get nine days over nine days you can
get this power this is sufficient to to
compile the mission I mean you will do
these things
refueling not during a mission in the
periods in which you are recovering so
it's quantized in probably the other way
of doing it would be to do a
katusha type of thing in other words
each tube is blowing separately but
that's this question of the technical
design now obviously this is an idea as
I said all ideas have a chance to not
work this is certainly a very high
probability not to work but still fun
worrying about first of all the behavior
or the armor issue and the stain extends
is exposure to hydrogen is the problem
the good news is that the that the Nerva
engine also has hydrogen and also has
fuel is not americium is uranium but
very similar chemically which is in
contact with hydrogen at high
temperature and it doesn't go away the
bad news of course is the deposition is
thin in the case of Nerva you got a
piece of solid rock
the other question radiative loss for
the hot gas is still some work to do
experimental work to do below 10,000
degrees that is essentially the rate of
no radiation if you go want to go above
that
the calculation one thing the
experiments are the other you gotta do
something about that now hydrodynamic
calculation obviously is the more
important point and there we have
questions like transformation in the
nozzle from plasma to the atom and the
atom to the molecule when it cools down
we have to understand what it does is
frozen flow etc and also other
possibilities are instead of using
hydrogen you use any other material and
one interesting material to use it would
be in lithium hydride lithium hydride is
a material which is solid at 650 degrees
boils becomes liquid and then you can
throw it into this system you it looks
like a solid fuel instead of being a
liquid fuel from a practical point of
view so you get less thrust but you do
have an advantage not to go around with
the normal sewers and eventually on the
five to ten years period we'll have to
do some testing so we are talking about
the test facility we should be large
enough to test fully open a few final
tubes now in Italy and in particular
also in America everywhere every time
you say a reactor everybody gets
reopened arm says my god you don't want
to do it etcetera etcetera so we decided
that we could also do it with a critic
subcritical facility it can be done the
whole round can be fed with neutrons
also from from an accelerator and in
this type of thing will allow you also
to produce americium after that and
essentially would allow to us to get a
faster track and the idea is to take one
of these tubes as I was indicating you
too enough meters longer and 40
centimeter diameter and they will give
you about a megawatt to power and
exhaust speed with 35 kilometers a
second and you can put that in a whole
round which can be made for instance
with the d2o
initially eventually then you can go to
lithium and they will be the supply
Neutron will be provided by an
accelerator which will give you some
neutrons in there and then you blow this
horn in this tube and then you collect
the gas it's not much gas the only 1.2
to g/s so you can you can pump it you
can freeze it and you can recycle so
that could be a model taking one of
these tubes make it work and then if you
understand one of those tubes you can do
more now obviously we were talking about
engines capable of doing man mission but
obviously you don't have to do that you
can use one tube of smaller devices to
to carry also instrumented missions for
instance the lots of instrument emission
which you could do with 10 20 tons of of
initial load rather than using the 150
tons which are required to to get onto
the main on Mars and there is what kind
of interesting things like the story by
Europa and so forth and so on I mean in
other words to get into this thing with
these devices remember this thing is
very modest here you only have hundred
grams this this device 80 grams of
Mauritian and 1.4 grams the second Oh
gas but still gives you about a megawatt
of thrust power so it's it's quite a
quite a quite a device doesn't that you
don't have to go to the gigantic device
with a you know Superman getting there
to start a thing like that it's
certainly already interesting enough for
a device it's trim extremely simple
there no moving parts there are no there
are no high high pressures
it's essentially a leaky tube in which
you put a little gas and and you get to
efficient fragments into it so it looks
like a quite a cute thing to try well I
finished with that thank you
[Applause]
not much the power going to the wall is
below 10,000 degrees it's very small oh
definitely definitely it's all included
I have a curve here see I have a curve
here Arthur here we have a heating power
of one point five megawatts and then
this is the power going on to the walls
integrated power watts and on the tube
and you see that if you go to 10,000
degrees you about 40 kilowatts so you
get 40 kilo it's a lap before the
kilowatts and but the power of the
fission fragments when enough megawatts
so in fact the amount of power coming
out is only core only the retrench
certain region see rise extremely
rapidly with that with with temperature
at 8,000 degrees there is nothing so
only the last little bit is emitted so
you will see very luminous core starting
8,000 degrees and going up to 10,000
that region there you will be quite a
quite a quite light but that volume is a
small fraction the total because most of
the work it which you do you do a lower
temperatures because they are used you
use pay the enthalpy of separating the
atom the mud molecule to the arrow and
that is where most of the work is and
then therefore there is a relatively
little gas which is very hot in it and
that justifies this thing but this is a
perfectly legitimate and exact
calculation using the correct cross
section for hydrogen atomic modes and
etc teller will complete simulation of
hydro etc including all kind of
sophistications it requires parallel
computing is a big program
takes 20 30 hours to compute and I think
it as far as computer is concerned is
the state-of-the-art now of course
reality may be different what
you first of all this thing is very
strong negative coefficient temperature
coefficient
therefore by putting the position of
your control rods you somehow define the
temperature define the temperature of
your of your device because if you when
it cools down it gets too high a
cross-section and therefore cake grows
but then when it gets hot it's it stops
at saturated so it's essentially there
is a very very strong negative
temperature coefficient and indeed you
just you can write the temperature on
your control rods and depending how
deeply you're putting in and out you
will fix the temperature operation of
the system so you can control the amount
of power now the second very variable
you have is amount of gas you get in and
now if you put in a lot of gas it will
go in and out rapidly and therefore it
will change substantially the operation
so the second control you have is that
one with the two things you can in fact
quite quite well cover thrust factors
about the factor 10 however when you
look at the mission you realize that
this kind of variable thrust of variable
in specific impulse whatever you want
it's more sophistication for
mathematicians that their reality that
when you you when you get there you go
to a flat own period and so I would
expect a 95% or 99% of the time and the
thing will run on and off what you do in
the mission you start first of all
pushing it and then and then when you
get close to Marcia to turn around and
then you have to slam to catch the
system so you have put their period
which the engines on it off but
essentially you don't have that much
room for doesn't seem necessary to have
high sophistication in the way the
engine is running you're not running in
downtown Boston and this is only for the
this is only for the trans planetary
travel then when you want to come then
you stay on a you have sensors to stand
by orbit one is the
and Space Station the other one should
be identical over Mars and then you have
transferred between the two most of it
is reducible by the way yes sir what do
you mean the conductivity and radiation
conductivity are in the program but
actually the conductivity of gas this
doesn't seem to be very very important
very strong what happens the gas starts
moving very slowly from the wall and
then moves slowly towards the center Hey
warming up it takes about a second one
second to go from from through the
system so it's a very very slow motion
and the corrections coming from heat
conductivity are not that important in
the long run they are irrelevant except
for the heat which goes to the to the
wall because if inside the gas there is
some heat exchange doesn't matter the
important thing is that you deliver the
power inside the gas to quick probably
on that but I am very happy to to come
back to it what I was saying here is
that we have a here we have a we have
here a liquid lithium inside this device
which is here and the lithium boils boil
more lithium produces some like in a
boiling water reactor born in lithium
reactor so you get vapor will heal it
you
the lithium vapor is separated here you
separate vapor from liquid the rest of
the liquid comes back and circulates
again into this in this volume and the
gas is sent to the today ray irradiation
panels which are
put all around the engine and which they
are operating about 1200 degrees so they
give you about 300 what is 300 kilowatts
per square meter something like that so
there are about a thousand square meters
something like that and they are
essentially foils in which the lithium
enters as a gap is a gas it condenses
all these tubes and then it comes back
in terms of liquid back the problem we
have seen there is that meteorites may
punch a hole into those walls
it may happen and therefore you have to
have a system in which the system is
sufficiently segmented ideally you have
some kind of wall valves or whatever
which avoid that kind of phenomenon but
at the temperature of 1200 degrees to
get rid of the heat is not not an
important problem of course that's that
mean this is just absolutely right you
are in this present approximation I'm
saying this heat is waste in reality
having a thousand degrees temperature
it's not a bad thing to use to do all
kind of different things with it
and therefore all the support energy and
transmission whatever will all be taken
out of that and by the way there are
very nice devices which are developed
apparently nowadays in Russia which are
thermionic devices they're using a very
narrow gap and they put a thermionic
emission in fact and you make it ironic
essentially put gas in there so that you
can get the high the space charge is
eliminated and they take a lot of lot of
powers of those things they get this
would be ideal for this device you will
have a thousand degrees you has like a
cathode of a vacuum tube and it will
emit electrons and those electrons will
give you one volt potential or something
like that
and then you will be able to recover a
fraction that energy directly on the
panels in form of of secondary emission
thermionic type of devices it's it's
it's very it there is plenty of
possibility using that heat is not just
garbage
there was some question there yes sir I
couldn't hear you what's that okay
very good question first of all a
professor Kerman will tell me that the
fission fragment are necessary because
without fission fragment and all delayed
neutrons and without delay neutrons
there is no reactor because reactors are
prominent so certain fraction the
fission fragment have to stay inside the
system if you throw them all out you
will have no possibility of controlling
the reactor now in reality as I said to
you about the 34% of the energy is in
fact carried from the gas into the guy
from the frische fragment to the ghast
remaining 2/3 of the fish and fragments
are in fact staying side material in
principle they should have to stay if
the foil is if we thin but if it's a
little thicker you stop more than so
about half of the fissure fragments will
stay inside implanted inside your foil
just as they do in a normally fuel in
normal fuel reactor they stay there and
they eventually get eliminated the other
half will go into the into the gossip
will obviously be exhausted in the
environment now obviously that is may be
problem indeed is not a problem because
we are talking about relatively small
amount of fuel we are talking about few
kilograms over the billion kilometres of
transfer between the Earth and Mars the
return and we are talking about a very
high speed of emission and the kind of
radioactivity garbage there is in in the
open space it's so large anyway that
this kind of fission fragment will no
believe will be able to detect them
anyway
so I don't think they represent the
problem by the way also never they're
thrown out you you know this this thing
goes off 35 kilometers 35 kilometers a
second it's a hundred thousand
kilometers an hour that's the speed in
which this thing comes out right right
it was good it was another question here
yes because they're very few because you
see the average temperature of the gas
the average temperature the gas is
10,000 degrees that means every atom is
one electron volt the fission fragment
is providing you hundred MeV
okay takes a lot of hundred a lot of
elect a lot of one electron volt atoms
for 100 MeV kinetic energy there's a
factor 10 to the 8th so the one fishing
fragment one fission fragment will heat
10 to the 8 hydrogen atoms and energy
conservation and so you see that you
have one electron volt outside there but
indeed you have you have 10 today to
start with so it's 10 to 8 to 1 10 to
the 7 to 1 something like that so there
will be 1 in 10 to the 7 110 to date
which will be official fragment that's
very small number it doesn't contribute
there are ideas people have proposed to
use fissure fragment directly as a
propulsion systems there are ideas in
which you take the fission fragment take
the foil don't put anything and let the
fission fragment go into space that will
give you push obviously the problem is
that the fission fragment will have a
very small push because they have a very
high speed and therefore they will give
you a very high specific impulse there
will be ideal for instance to go to
outside the solar system if you want to
go to the
- - it nearby Sun you will need the
fission fragment propulsion in this case
you will not put the hydrogen you will
just make the system and let the fission
fragment come out they would come up
with a speed of four percent of the
speed of light and therefore they will
be optimal when the rocket will go to
four percent the speed of light so it
will make in in 20 times 120 20 times
the light speed light distance so you'll
get there so if you are five light-years
five times twenty in a hundred years
you'll get to the neighboring and Sun
you can make a mission of that type that
for that case you will need the official
Frank directly it would work the same
way I mean there's nothing wrong with
that you will not put hydrogen let them
out fix them other people haven't even
thought about it in the past using
sources and so forth California and so
forth that will be good if you were to
have much higher speeds but here you
want to have very modest job you want to
fill the gap between normal chemical and
and this kind of vast proportions so you
need a lot of stuff with a relative
small speed to get clear sufficient
thrust with a modest power because the
power goes like MV squared
there's the trust cosine V so if you
have a very high speed for a given power
you get a little trust but you get high
quality trust so eventually you could do
that you just run your system with empty
let this fission fragment go and then
you will get you get much very kindly
trust but they will go for will be on
even if your spacecraft gets speeds
which are very closely one a speed of
light it's somewhere in between between
that and antimatter if you like it's my
view is but it's very simple as in
apparatus because it just have a layer
which emits official fragment in space
so it can be very reliable you can think
of having the damn thing running for a
long time yes sir
we this power which is coming back
because of radiation there was a
question Arthur Herman had what happens
of the light emitted by the hot plasma
how much there is there and how much is
the effect on the walls and that is
small effect well I was explaining you
that I am taking the same kind of
situation as a normal reactor let's take
a normal reactor in a normal reactor
your fuel rods the fuel rod produces
about 200-300 watts per square
centimeter that rod is immersed inside
the sodium for instance super Phoenix or
other liquid if you have a different
machines and this liquid takes away the
heat correct
now imagine that that rod now is changed
I remove the inside the fuel which is
inside and I replace it with an empty
tube which I put some hydrogen that's my
business and I transform the fuel from
being solid all the way to the center
just to be on the periphery if I put
that fuel on the periphery my cooling
will go much better because there were
no conductivity problem inside the fuel
itself rod but the amount of power per
unit surface is the same as the previous
one so in the same way I was able to run
a reactor with that power density I'm be
able to run this quota quad reactor with
empty rods I empty the rods I go for two
dimensional to three dimension to
surface you follow me so all the
thermodynamics is already solved by any
ordinary reactor guy I will calculate my
own engine in such a way as if I have no
hydrogen is turned off the hydrogen
accidentally and their fizz all the
power goes to the fission fragment I'll
have enough cooling to make it work
it is a normal reactor where all the
power goes into fission fragment then
becomes heating so you see there is a
continuity between building a reactor
being this machine if any when you make
this machine you have it better off they
are in a reactor but no but I forget
about that I designed the machine in
such a way that even if there is no gas
I don't want to have a meltdown and this
is famous 200 watt 2 square centimeters
which is the normal power in super
Phoenix and Phoenix in in other versions
which are run in the world who will be
metal so you know it's like you replace
your rod with the name T rod I am
designing the machine in such a way that
the full power can be dissipated away in
still machine works because it's a
switch of the hydrogen then all the
freaks Fischer Frank we will return
inside the lair on the other side and
have to be prepared for that
but the gas is the point is they stop in
the gas 20 times more efficiently the
point is that the gas is in its very
viscous is very very effective in
stopping the fission fragments while the
others is not is you see the difference
arrange the factor 20 to 1 so the power
density in the gas is very high this is
why you get a mega watts per gram with
200 watts per square centimeter on the
surface yes sir
30 50 milliseconds there are acoustic
you could you could hear them coming and
going you know they just go for you know
they go about they go about three or
four hundred times back and forth
they're traveling a kilometer per second
that's it under thermal speed so one
second 1000 meters per second so it
tells to meter per second right is the
speed of neutrons right they go sixty
meters they go three meters it should
cross it so a hundred times is 300
meters so a thousand meter per second
300 meters is about 0.3 seconds so does
neutral stay forever they stay for if
you could hear it you get the neutral in
and when it comes out you say bingo
bingo you can hear the two sawing sounds
you should be able to sound separately
like in the sonar yes
no we I mean I try to and this is a good
question I think it's important it's
clarified I don't believe you can send a
man on a home on trajectory one year to
get there 700 days 640 days to wait for
the good time and then another year to
come back besides if it's American every
years to pay his taxes that's the law so
you need a special waiver so anyway so
evidently this is not possible in the
mission 3.0 NASA one assumes that you
get there and you manufacture your own
fuel there so you get there for the
first time your life in condition which
is extremely harsh you stay there for
one and for 600 days which is two years
and a little boxes and then you have to
make you on fuel and if you need a extra
gasket spare parts would be hard to find
correct and then you come back it's a
another F and by the way also there is a
fundamental point we just do the
radiation we have calculate the amount
of radiation dose that you get by
staying there and it's very large the
fact that Mars is a very thin amount of
air it's enhances the radiation because
you get a maximum of the cosmic rays and
even if you go on the ground you have to
go on the ground something like 510
meters before you can get rid of the
whole thing and in fact you get sky
shine from the walk from the from the
from the soil
you sit there do all this cosmic rays go
inside the the soil and then come back
nice neutrons which you get into your
body and so forth so so the dose it's
it's enormous it's it's it's larger than
Chernobyl firemen so the risk of a very
long trip is primarily a radiation
hazard in my view and it's my view it's
very much limited which you can accept
50% survival probability stuff like that
already on the moon there was a lot of
radiation given to the zoster nods
people don't underline that but that was
a very short trip here we're talking
about three years four years five years
away from home
now obviously the question is do you
need a man over there in my view for
mourning many things you don't need a
man you can send a test device etc but
this machinery will be so complicated
that you need somebody to go and fix
them look at the Hubble telescope if you
don't send a guy up there to change the
window it will not be possible to repair
it and similar thing will happen also
over to Mars so Mars is a planet it's
very complicated thing you have to do
enormous amount of exploration to do
that lots of experiments stable studies
and not just touch go and touch touching
go it's it's it's not like it's it is
the real planet with a complicated story
and so forth and so on it's at them so
you will have a lot of equipment there
which you run more or less automatically
but it will need now and then amend do
to fix it to install it to modify it etc
so you need presence of men in space but
not total presence only in a short
period of time so we are devising a
emission in which you go there on a very
short track you go ten hundred fifty
days you've stayed the Air Force for a
limited period of time with no time
window so if today you cannot do it if
it's a dust Tempest or whatever you can
go back tomorrow and then you come back
and then this you can do with the
periodicity which is a 740 days which is
the super periodicity of the Sun of the
system in the meantime you send the
cargo but you can take all the try to
get there and with a lot of stuff a lot
of equipment which you install in your
operate so the idea is that you have
cargos which bring the largest amount of
material you can there this specific
impulse is useful because it reduces the
increases the efficiency of the payload
and you get there with a substantial
payload and and then you leave it there
essentially it's dead it never comes
back the engine the target comes back
empty and the interest stays there and
and then
send a human mission periodically to
update the system to improve the system
to collect the data to fix whatever is
to be fixed to take the decision but on
a short period of time and that applies
by about fifty hundred days to stay
there and 150 days to come back and
forth this is possible with these kind
of engines is impossible with the
chemical that from Brown is already
proven it's marginally possible probably
impossible as well also with nervous the
other problem is also the question of
putting in space amount of fissionable
material here americium is very similar
to pollute the two plutonium-238 as I
said it's a munition is 1/3 toxicity of
plutonium-238 roughly same life time and
so we are bringing hazard which is
comparable to this generator already
used to put a ton of highly fissile
material in orbit
well there are presumably reactor in
orbit but they belong to security you
know classified activities of some
unspecified country but in practice if
you make a thing like this you can't go
with a ton of uranium I hope hope the
people will let you get away with it
[Applause]
you